WAI CHEE DIMOCK: And this is
actually the historic end of the
Spanish Civil War.
Obviously, the Republicans
lost. They were
on the losing side.
And the winner gets to appear on
the cover of Time Magazine.
March 27, 1939, General
Franco there.
So even though it actually
ended slightly later than
that, but already at that point
it was clear that there
was no way the fascists
would not win.
So that's why he was on the
cover of Time Magazine.
So what we're looking at,
obviously, is some time before
that, when things are still
basically up in the air.
And so, when you get to the
end of For Whom the Bell
Tolls, actually there's still
hope for Robert in many ways.
And so we'll be looking
at that at the
end of today's lecture.
But I also want to call your
attention to a very
interesting fact about the
Spanish Civil War, which is
that it was very much a women's
war, unlike World War
I or, indeed, World War II,
where there weren't a lot of
women doing the actual
fighting.
The Spanish Civil War was one
that was very proud of the
fact that women were
participating in a fairly
significant way.
So we can see that both in the
posters celebrating that fact,
but also in numerous photos that
we have of women either
training or actually in
combat situations.
There's one of them.
They were trained just as a man
would be trained, and they
were in uniform.
And this was a woman militia
from Barcelona, I think.
And, once more, women
fighting.
So partly I think that accounts
for the fact that
Pilar is such a powerful figure
in For Whom the Bell
Tolls, that this is one of the
few Hemingway novels where
there's a fairly strong
woman's voice.
We might think that maybe she's
too good to be true,
that maybe it's overly
idealized, but, in any case,
Pilar is a rare instance of a
very powerful woman who would
dare to cast her judgment,
pass her judgment, on the
conduct of her own side.
And she thought that the
revolution had begun badly, as
we saw last time.
A woman who's not afraid
to have that opinion.
So partly it had to do with the
fact that the women were
so important in the Spanish
Civil War as soldiers, but I
think that it also has something
to do with the
personal circumstances in
Hemingway's own life.
If you turn to the front of
For Whom the Bell Tolls,
you'll see that it's dedicated
to Martha Gelhorn.
Hemingway was married to Martha
Gelhorn when they were
writing, when they
were covering the
Spanish Civil War.
And she very much was
a very important
journalist in her own right.
So this is the book that she
wrote, both about the Spanish
Civil War, but also about World
War II, and in fact
about Vietnam.
It went all the way
to the '60s.
So she really had a very long,
distinguished career as a war
journalist. And in recognition
of the fact, there actually
was a United States postage
stamp celebrating her writing,
with her wartime writings
from Japan and China.
The Chinese Revolution was a
very important part of her
writing, and in Normandy
and Dachau, the
World War II episodes.
So I was tempted, actually, to
read some of her writing, but
there's just no room to
incorporate her wartime
reporting into this class.
But I just want to draw your
attention to the fact that she
was actually a very significant
companion to
Hemingway in more
ways than one.
So today we'll be talking about
basically the narrative
form of Hemingway.
And you guys will be getting
paper topics very soon from
your the teaching fellows, and
one of the topics will have to
do with forms of narration,
the narrative structure.
So I want to start talking about
that, and to get you
guys thinking about various
experimental or well
rehearsed, but nonetheless still
reinvigorated, forms in
this novel.
So we'll be looking at questions
of symmetry, and a
mirror effect that already we've
seen a little bit of.
Last time we talked about
negative mirroring, the earth
moving for Robert Jordan and
Maria when they made love, and
that being mirrored negatively
with the bombing when the
earth moved under the feet of
the people who were bombed.
So that's one instance of
negative symmetry, something
being ironized retroactively.
Today we'll be looking
at more instances of
those kinds of symmetry.
So obviously, possession
and dispossession, have
and have not --
a longstanding paradigm that
we've been looking at --
ironic and not ironic.
And then, also, ending and
beginning, very important in
this novel.
But I want to begin by looking
at one particular symmetry,
which is the symmetry of
brutality, or brutal conduct.
Execution that we saw, the
execution of the fascists that
we saw last time
in Chapter 10.
And then in Chapter 31,
a similar, maybe more
horrendous, episode of fascist
violence, the rape that is
inflicted on Maria.
So it really goes back, also, to
the importance of women in
the Spanish Civil War as well.
And because rape is such an of
explosive subject, there's
been lots done on rape.
This is Susan Brownmiller's
Against Our Will, it's one of
the classic considerations
of rape.
There also has been lots and
lots of representation of rape
in painting, especially rape
considered as a metaphor for
the brutalities perpetrated on
the defeated by the victors.
So even though it's the women
who are getting raped, it
really is a metaphor for
what happens to the
losers in the war.
So Poussin actually had
a number of paintings.
I can't even keep count of
the significant number.
This is one, and this is another
one at the Louvre, a
very well known painting.
It can get monotonous
after a while.
They are different, but they're
also quite a bit alike.
So when Picasso came to redoing
this theme, you can
see that this is a real
new departure.
It looks nothing like the
Poussin paintings.
And so that is the twentieth
century take on a very time
honored theme.
And I would argue that Hemingway
is, in his own way,
doing a novelistic rendition
of the rape of the Sabine
women in the rape of just one
particular woman, Maria.
And I would argue that it is
every bit as innovative as the
Picasso painting, coming out at
the same time, a complete
departure from tradition.
So what is innovative about
Hemingway, and it actually
goes back to his longstanding
interest in the mirror and
looking at yourself
in the mirror.
The last time we saw that when
Robert was dropping the gun,
the pistol that was misused by
his father, he was looking at
himself his mirror image in the
water, looking at himself
holding the gun and
dropping the gun.
So we've already seen one
instance of the mirror in For
Whom the Bell Tolls, and this
is a much more traumatic
instance of that.
"I saw my face in the mirror
of the barbershop and the
faces of three others who were
leaning over me and I knew
none of the faces but in the
glass I saw myself and them,
but they saw only me.
And it was as though one were
in the dentist's chair and
there were many dentists and
they were all insane.
My own face I could hardly
recognize because my grief had
changed it but I looked at it
and knew that it was me.
But my grief was so great that
I had no fear nor any feeling
but my grief."
So this is not actually
the rape, it's just
cutting off her hair.
In many ways an innocuous
exercise, but the rape would
come after that.
And Maria doesn't talk about
the actual rape.
So this is all as close as we
can get, is the looking at
herself in the mirror.
And I think it is a belated
rejoinder to the earlier
episode of Robert looking at his
own face in the water, in
a sense that this is associated
with trauma for
some reason.
To look at ones self in the
mirror is a traumatic tableau
for Hemingway.
It's the precondition for
some kind of trauma.
In the case of the earlier
episode with Robert looking at
himself mirrored in the water,
it's actually the beginning of
the cleansing process.
He's ridding himself of that
pistol that he would want to
have nothing to do with.
In this case, Maria looking at
herself in the mirror as the
rape is about to happen is the
beginning of the trauma.
So let's look at the visual
tableau that Hemingway is
creating for us.
Because of the optics, the
particular optics of this
scene, Maria can see herself
and then the three of them.
And they can look in
the mirror and
they see only Maria.
So this is a great example of
how self-consciousness is, in
many ways, the burden of the
person who is tortured.
The people who are doing the
torturing see only the object
of the torture.
So they get all the pleasure
from being able to inflict
maximum damage on the person
that they are torturing.
They don't see themselves
doing it.
That's what enables them to do
it is that they don't see
themselves.
Maria sees herself, and she sees
the three people who are
able to do this to her.
And what we're beginning to
see is, in many ways, the
beginning of the process
of this procession.
Maria looks at herself, but
because of those three looming
figures behind her, already
she's not quite herself.
She is herself plus those
three other people.
And she's also not quite
herself because they're
cutting off her hair.
So she's losing a very
important part of her identity.
So she's beginning not
to recognize herself.
And this process of not
recognizing herself would get
dramatized in a way that goes
back, actually, to the image
of the two lines that we had
talked about, and that Robert
Motherwell also represented
in numerous paintings.
The two orderly lines that would
be the utopian ideals of
political ritual in the
execution of the fascists.
In this case it is, once
again, a retroactive
ironization of that earlier
utopian moment.
We get the same two lines,
except that those two lines
now have a completely
different meaning.
"At that time I wore my hair in
two braids and I watched in
the mirror one of them lifted
one of the braids and pulled
on it so it hurt me suddenly
through my grief and then cut
it off close to my head
with a razor.
And I saw myself with one braid
and a slash where the
other had been.
Then he cut off the other braid
but without pulling on
it and the razor made a small
cut on my ear and I saw blood
come from it.
'Cans't thou feel the scar with
thy finger?' 'Yes.
But would it be better
not to talk of
this?' 'This is nothing.
I will not talk of that
which is bad.'
So he had cut both braids close
to my head with a razor
and the others laughed and I did
not even feel the cut on
my ear and then he stood in
front of me and struck me
across the face with the braids
while the other two
held me and he said, 'This
is how we make Red nuns.
This will show thee
how to unite with
thy proletarian brothers.
Bride of the Red Christ!
And he struck me again and again
across the face with the
braids which had been mine and
then he put the two of them in
my mouth and tied them tight
around my neck, knotting them
in the back to make a gag and
the two holding me laughed."
So this is the new use to
which lines could be--
the two braids belonging to
oneself can be used as weapons
against oneself.
So this is very much the same
logic as the earth rising up
and hitting the men that have
been rushing up to this point.
So it's really the complete
reversal of the meaning of
something that really is a
part of you, and radical
alienation of that thing, and
the instrumentalization of
that thing into a weapon.
But even then, I think it's less
traumatic than the effect
of looking at the mirror and
watching yourself losing first
one braid and then the other,
and then watching the
transformation of your face
when that is happening.
It is not only inflicting that
on Maria, but also making her
watch herself undergo this
transformation, that she's
becoming an alien being
even to her own eyes.
So this is the conclusion of
that act of dispossession.
"Then the one who had gagged me
ran a clipper all over my
head; first from the forehead
all the way to the back of the
neck and then across the top and
then all over my head and
close behind my ears and they
held me so I could see into
the glass of the barber's mirror
all the time that they
did this and I could not believe
it as I saw it done
and I cried and cried but I
could not look away from the
horror that my face made with
the mouth open and the braids
tied it in and my head coming
naked under the clippers."
So this is the closest that
Hemingway will get to giving
us an image of Maria being
rendered completely
defenseless, because all the
things that shelter ourselves
are being taken away from her.
Hair might not be the most
powerful form of shelter, but
it is a form of shelter in the
sense that without it we
really look very naked, naked
in a psychological sense.
And Maria will become naked
in more than that sense.
But it also has to do with
what kind of object Maria
would be in the world.
Before this happens, she would
never be an object to herself.
She should always be a subject
to herself, in a sense that
she would never actually see
herself as she's seeing
herself right now.
So it is really taking away
her relation to herself.
That is being taken
away from her.
It's not even just the hair,
which is nothing, which will
grow back, although we can also
see that Hemingway is
quite obsessed with hair and the
cutting off of hair, just
as Fitzgerald is in "Bernice
Cuts Her Hair." But the
physical removal of the hair
is really nothing compared
with the destruction of a
longstanding relation that one
has to oneself.
And I think that we see a
similar operation when someone
would insult you to the point
where you don't actually
recognize the person who
has been insulted.
It might not ever have happened
to you, and very
rarely it happens to anyone, but
Zora Neale Hurston talks
about that in an essay called,
"How I Became the Colored Me."
It was then when she was
growing up in a black
community in Florida, but she
never saw herself as black
until she was made to feel
herself as black.
So it's losing one kind of
identity to oneself.
And what is happening here is
a similar kind of situation,
that suddenly she sees herself
as something that she's never
seen herself as before.
So it is both that operation,
but also the additional horror
that she cannot take her eyes
away from the mirror.
She could easily have
shut her eyes.
So the psychological atrocity
of this scene is that the
dynamics of the scene is such
that she cannot take her eyes
away from this thing that she
cannot bear to watch.
It is the gluing of her eyes
to something that she would
want to do everything to
remove her eyes from.
It is that gluing that is also
part of the atrocity.
So it is the way that Hemingway
chooses to talk
about rape, not the very,
completely recognizable
scenario that Poussin has made
classic in his classic
compositions.
And not even the Picasso
representation, which still
has to do much more with someone
crying out in protest.
We can almost hear the sound in
the Picasso representation.
In the Maria episodes there is
absolutely no sound, because
her mouth has been gagged.
So it's the absolute silencing
of Maria, and the complete
reduction of that scenario into
a visual scenario without
sound in both the Poussin and
the Picasso painting.
What makes it slightly bearable
is that we can
imagine those women
as crying out.
And it is that crying out that
makes them human and registers
the resistance to what is
being done to them.
In the case of Maria, because
it is strictly a mirror
effect, and because it is a
strictly visual tableau, and
because her mouth is gagged,
it is completely soundless.
So it is the deprivation of
voice, along with the cutting
of the hair, it's those two
things that work to create the
maximum effect of
victimization in the rape
scenes.
So we can see that, for Maria,
dispossession is a central
narrative fact.
And it is registered with
full dramatic effect as
unforgettable, an instance of
rape as any in American
literature, but actually
representing the act itself.
So that is part of the
innovation as well, is that
you don't actually go anywhere
near the actual deed.
Given the fact that
dispossession is so important
for Maria, I think
that we have to
ask a related question.
To what extent is
dispossession central for
Robert?
I think it is an
open question.
I hope that you guys will talk
about it in section.
It's whether or not Maria
actually gets to recover from
that act of dispossession.
Has she recovered fully from
that rape, or is she still
living in the shadow
of that rape?
How long does it take for
that shadow to go away?
Is she still within the
narrative of dispossession all
the way through For Whom
the Bell Tolls?
So that's an open question
for Maria.
For Robert it's a slightly
different question, and it has
to do with two possible
trajectories for Robert.
And so what I would like to
do here is to give you a
demonstration of one way to
write your final paper, which
is to write half of the paper as
dedicated to one argument,
and the other half
as dedicated to
the opposite argument.
So this would be an interesting
experiment to do.
Basically you're trying
to be a lawyer.
Lawyers are supposed to argue
either side of a case.
It's an intellectual exercise.
Usually it takes, for most
of us, it takes a little
bit more that that.
We actually have to have some
kind of emotional investment
in something to argue, to make
a very convincing case.
But supposedly someone who's
trained as a lawyer should be
able to argue either side.
So what I'm offering you as one
possibility in the final
paper is to make an argument
one way and then in exactly
the opposite way.
And in this case it's not even
a stretch for me to argue of
both sides of the case,
because actually I'm
completely torn in my mind.
So actually, there is the
emotional investment on my
part, in both sides
of the argument.
So the two opposing arguments,
obviously one would be that
For Whom the Bell Tolls is a
narrative about dispossession,
that what Robert ends up with at
the end of the novel is as
a "have not." That he starts out
with something, and by the
end of the novel everything
is taken away from him.
He is completely empty handed
at the end of the novel.
A very harsh reading
of the novel.
The other, and I like to end
with that, is to argue that it
actually is a narrative
of repossession.
Yes, that a lot has been taken
away from him, but that maybe
we could still make a case that
he's not totally empty
handed at the end
of the novel.
And so I hope I'll be able to
make a compelling case for
both, but let's start
with trajectory one.
And, obviously, in order to make
a case for Robert as a
have not I think that we have
to put an ironic spin on the
word "to have," especially a
memorable line, "Roberto, what
hast thou?" And I want to bring
back, actually to a
similar use, ironic
use, of the word
"have" in As I Lay Dying.
And following from that, we
can look at the narrative
structure of For Whom the Bell
Tolls, and look at it as a
narrative enactment in terms of
the formal structure of the
novel, as a narrative enactment
of the act of
dispossession, that
Robert is losing
control of the narrative.
That an arm and a leg has been
cut off from him and taken
over by someone else, and
comparing that with maybe a
similar situation in To
Have and Have Not.
So first, to have as
an ironic word.
This is at the very
end of the novel.
"Maria was kneeling by him and
saying, 'Roberto, what hast
thou?' He said, sweating
heavily, 'The left leg is
broken, guapa.' The
sweat-streaked, bristly face
bent down by him and Robert
Jordan smelt the
full smell of Pablo.
'Let us speak,' he said to Pilar
and Maria, 'I have to
speak to Pablo.'
'Does it hurt much?'
Pablo asked.
He was bending close
over Robert Jordan.
'No, I think the nerve
is crushed.
Listen.
Get along.
I am mucked, see?
I will talk to the girl for a
moment.' 'Clearly, there's not
much time.'
'Clearly.' 'I think you would
do better in the Republic,'
Robert Jordan said.
'Nay, I am for Grados.' 'Use
thy head.' 'Talk with her
now,' Pablo said.
'There is little time.
I am sorry thou hast this,
Ingles.' 'Since I have it,'
Robert Jordan said, 'let
us not speak of it.
But use thy head.
Thou hast much head.
Use it.'"
It is very hard to not to notice
the way that the key
player in this passage is the
word to have. It begins with
Maria asking Robert, innocently,
"What hast thou,"
because, in fact, she doesn't
know whether the
leg is really broken.
But he knows.
And it's at this point --
it's the switching of Pablo
for Maria that, for me,
represents one of the cruel
decisions on Hemingway's part.
That, instead of having Maria
still bending over him, the
person who's now bent over
Robert is Pablo, and what he
smells is the full
smell of Pablo.
It's a very, very significant
detail in the sense that
Robert still doesn't
really know Pablo.
He remains a mysterious figure
all the way through.
I mentioned last time that
a lot of things happen.
Pablo does a lot of things.
He thinks lots of things when
we're not privy to what is
going on in the narrative.
And, likewise for Robert, he
simply doesn't know what's
going on inside Pablo's head,
or what Pablo is doing.
He's executing other people
when Robert isn't looking.
So all this we suspect might
be happening, but we just
never know.
So Pablo is, from beginning to
end, he's always an opaque
character both to Robert
and to us.
But all that Robert can get
at this moment is the
full smell of Pablo.
It is that overwhelming odor,
almost like the smell of
honeysuckle that is coming to
Robert at the end of his life.
That is about the most that he
will ever get, it's not a
cerebral understanding of Pablo,
it's just an animal
apprehension of how powerful
a man this is, smells in an
animal sense.
And it's an animal's fear and
apprehension, but also a
recognition of what kind
of a man Pablo is.
So Pablo asks an innocent enough
question, "Does it hurt
much?" But he knows
that there's no
way Robert can travel.
There's no way he can go with
the rest of the people.
He knows perfectly well
how much time,
really, is left to Robert.
And there is an up front,
cruelly, I think, in the last
thing that Pablo says to Robert,
"I'm sorry thou hast
this, Ingles." From beginning
to end, the refusal of
recognition that Robert is
American and English, that he
has a name, even.
For Pablo, Robert is just like
Kashkin someone with a rare
name who comes in, who destroys
the bridge, destroys
something, works the explosive,
is killed.
He is another of those.
A whole string of foreigners
coming though with totally
forgettable names, and
not even getting
the nationality right.
So this is the ultimate insult
inflicted by Pablo on Robert
at the very end of his life.
And Robert is absolutely
defenseless.
He's defenseless physically,
he's defenseless
psychologically and
emotionally.
All he can say is, in fact,
this admission of defeat
really, giving the last
bit of advice,
telling Pablo to go back.
They are behind their enemy's
lines so they are actually in
Fascist nationalist territory,
and he advises Pablo to go
back to the Spanish Republic.
But Pablo says no, I'm actually
going to go further
away from the Spanish
Republic.
I'm for Grados.
And actually, it turns out to
be a really smart decision,
because if they had gone back
to the Spanish Republic they
would actually all
have been killed.
So Robert is actually right to
end with the last line, "Thou
hast much head."
The symmetry here is between
Robert having a broken leg and
Pablo having much head.
He's the brainy one.
This is the ultimate rewriting
of the power dynamics in For
Whom The Bell Tolls.
We've been going along on the
assumption that it's the
person with the knowledge or
the technology, the person
with the knowledge of the world,
the person who can
speak several languages, we've
been going on the assumption
that that person is going to
be on top, that the future
belongs to him.
The ultimate irony of this novel
is, in fact, this is the
person who's going to lose out,
who has no future at all.
So in many ways we can either
say it is a very brutal
undoing of everything that
Robert has believed in, or we
can say it actually is a kind
of inverted, utopian vision,
that there is still a future for
the Spanish peasants, even
though they seem so
disadvantaged in a modern
world, even though they seem
completely incapable of
functioning outside of their
very limited environment.
Because they are capable of
functioning within their very
limited environment.
Actually, they have a chance
to survive, at least that's
the narrative that Hemingway's
giving us.
So a negative utopia for Robert
and a positive utopia
for Pablo, and it is ironic,
but I don't think that it
actually is.
It's fully ironic that Pablo
should be the embodiment of
some kind of utopian hope
at the end of the novel.
And just to give you a
comparison for similar use of
the verb to be in
As I Lay Dying,
almost exactly the same.
"Cash has a broken leg.
He has had two broken legs.
He lies on the box with a quilt
rolled under his head
and a piece of wood
under his knee.
"'I reckon we ought to
have left him at
Armstid's,' pa says.
'I haven't got a broken leg and
pa hasn't and Darl hasn't
and 'It's just the bumps,'
Cash says.
'It kind of grinds together
a little on a bump.
It don't bother none.'"
So exactly.
Hemingway and Fitzgerald have
the same intuition about the
extent to which the word to
have can be ironized.
So given the fact that Robert
has arrived at his
destination, which is this state
of dispossession at the
end of the novel, we should
not be surprised that that
destination is well prepared
for, some ways, before that.
So I just want to call your
attention to the narrative
innovation in For Whom the
Bell Tolls, which is the
removal of the narrative
from Robert Jordan.
He doesn't get to
tell the story.
There are four chapter told by
someone else, quite literally
cutting off the narrative
from Robert.
And those four chapters are the
chapters when Andres, who
is charged with the mission to
go and deliver this very
important message to the central
command, that actually
the enemy knew that they were
going to launch this attack,
that very important information
that was going to
be conveyed by Andres is told
in four chapters that have
absolutely nothing to
do with Robert.
So let me just give you one
instance of that removal of
the narrative from Robert.
Chapter 40, he's a non
protagonist, he's a non
participant, he doesn't show
up at all in that chapter.
"During the time that Robert
Jordan had slept through, the
time he had spent planning the
destruction of the bridge and
the time that he had been
with Maria, Andres
had made slow progress.
Until he had reached the
Republican lines he had
travelled across country and
through the fascist lines as
fast as a countryman in good
physical condition who knew
the country well could
travel in the dark.
But once inside Republican lines
it went very slowly."
So there's irony right here,
that we detect, that for
Andres, this is very dramatic,
because actually it takes so
much more time to travel
through, supposedly, your own
side, because he's questioned
and detained by everyone.
Whereas it's much faster to go
through enemy terrain because
it's just traveling as someone
who is physically fit can
travel, which is very fast.
So those four chapters, 34,
36, 40, and 42, those four
chapters are devoted to the
irony of how slow it is and
how impossible it is for
Andres to deliver
that crucial message.
But the other additional irony
is that Robert is fast
becoming a non-protagonist in
his own narrative, which is
very much a prelude
to the end.
At the end of For Whom the Bell
Tolls he will be a non
player in the future of
the Spanish Republic.
He will be a non-player in
Maria's life, in Pablo's life,
in everyone's life.
And Hemingway has already paved
the way for Robert being
a non-player much earlier.
So we can think back to many
other instances of someone
being a non player.
In "Soldier's Home" in In
Our Time, Krebs being a
non-player, his sister playing
basketball and Krebs being on
the sideline, being
a non-player.
So Hemingway has given a lot of
thought for what it means
for a man who once used to be
an important player to be
relegated to the sidelines and
to suffer the fate of being a
non-player.
And he is enacting that
one more time in For
Whom the Bell Tolls.
So I just wanted to highlight
the interconnections among
Hemingway's works.
This is not the first time
when he has removed the
narrative from the supposed
protagonist of that narrative.
In To Have and Have Not a
similar fate has been visited
upon Harry Morgan.
So in chapters one to five, told
from Harry Morgan's point
of view, chapter six, all
of a sudden, he's
referred to as a man.
"'You ain't gonna fix me
up,' the nigger said.
The man, whose name was Harry
Morgan, said nothing back,
because he liked the nigger and
there was nothing to do
now but hit him, and he
couldn't hit him."
When we were talking about
this passage we said that
suddenly Harry becomes Harry
Morgan, someone looked at
completely from the outside,
and who is, in fact, put in
the same position as
the black person.
They've both lost something.
And in a more abstract way, we
can also just go back to that
moment at the very end of
For Whom the Bell Tolls.
Robert is still Robert Jordan.
He never gets to the
stage where he
can simply be a Robert.
He's still referred to in
that alienating form.
So that, too, the structure is
very much similar to the
alienating device in To
Have and Have Not.
I think that I've done
everything that I can to make
a case for To Have and Have
Not as a novel of
dispossession.
That basically Robert emerges as
completely empty handed at
the end of the novel.
He's lost his leg, he's
lost Maria, he's
about to lose his life.
He's lost even a novel that
is supposedly his.
So it is a loss, almost
completely equal, to the loss
of Darl at the end of
As I Lay Dying.
And it really is possible read
both Hemingway and Faulkner as
authors who have dedicated to
the bleakest vision possible
of human possibilities.
But I want to, now, make the
opposite case, which is that
it's not quite as
bleak as that.
That maybe there's a way in
which we can think about the
verb to have as a somewhat
non-ironic word.
And also, that there's a way to
read the narrative not as
one that highlights or maybe
passes the damning verdict
that there really is nothing
at the end for Robert.
So trying to recover something
for Robert at
the end of the narrative.
So it turns out that Hemingway
is also quite self conscious
about using to verb to have
as a non-ironic verb.
This is a little earlier, so
it has the disadvantage of
coming before that final very
ironic moment, but it's still
a moment we should look at.
"And another thing.
Don't ever kid yourself
about loving someone.
It is just that most people
are not lucky enough
ever to have it.
You never had it before
and now you have it.
What you have with Maria,
whether it last just through
today and a part of tomorrow, or
whether it lasts for a long
life, is the most important
thing that can happen to a
human being.
There will always be people
who say it does not exist
because they cannot have it.
But I tell you it is true that
you have it and that you are
lucky even if you
die tomorrow."
So this is, relatively speaking,
an instance where we
have the verb to have in an
unironic, non-ironic mode,
that it's affirming the privacy
and the durability of
what he had, or has, or
continues to have with Maria.
But we also know that, even in
this non-ironic moment, the
verb to have is very
precarious.
It is precarious because it is
so much dependent on being
able to refute other people who
would not credit you with
having that thing.
So it is this consciousness
that there will always be
people who say it does
not exist because
they cannot have it.
Because what you have here, what
Robert has here, is so
intangible, because there's
really no material way to
demonstrate it.
It is there, it simply
is not a physical
object in the world.
There's no material evidence
that it is a
thing in the world.
All you have is your subjective
intuition that you
did have it, that you
continue to have it.
And then having it makes
all the difference.
It is only a subjective
conviction.
It doesn't carry the weight of
objective demonstrability.
And so that is one strike
against it, that other people
will not be persuaded by the
fact that you did have it.
They will continue to tell
you that you didn't.
The other thing, which I think
actually plays out on a formal
level, has to do with
the switch of
pronouns in this passage.
All the way through this passage
the pronouns are
already switched.
Even though Robert has been
just talking in the first
person singular, I, in this
critical moment he's actually
referring to himself as you.
"You never had it before
and now you have it."
And even more powerfully in the
last line, where we see
both the pronoun I and the
pronoun you, "But I tell you
it is true that you have it and
that you're lucky even if
you die tomorrow." The
co-presence of the pronoun I
and the pronoun you suggest
that it is an effort.
It takes some real power
to convince himself
that he did have it.
I'm telling you that
you did have it.
It's not just that other people
are not persuaded, but
Robert himself has to be
convinced, he has to be beaten
over the head by this other I
to believe that, yes, that
what he did have with Maria
does make a difference and
does make him a "have."
So because of those two
considerations I would say
that this is a non-ironic use
of the word "to have," but
heavily circumscribed with other
possibilities looming
heavily on the horizon.
And it's replayed in the very
last moment of the novel.
"He looked down the hill slope
again and he thought, I hate
to leave it, is all.
I hate to leave it very much
and I hope I have done some
good in it.
I have tried to with
what talent I had.
Have, you mean.
All right, have. I have fought
for what I believed
in for a year now.
If we win here we will
win everywhere.
The world is a fine place and
worth the fighting for and I
hate very much to leave it.
And you had a lot of luck, he
told himself, to have had such
a good life.
You've had just as good a
life as grandfather's
though not so long.
You've had just as good a life
as any one because of these
last days."
So once again, non-ironic use
of the verb to have, but
taking an effort of the will
to convince himself.
He has to be told you've had
as good a life as your
grandfather.
You've had as good
a life as anyone.
It has to be a command issued
by part of himself.
And so it takes that form, that
it is not a natural or
unselfconscious conviction.
It's a conviction arrived at
through some struggle and with
quite a bit of effort.
So Robert, I think, is actually
a very fragile
vehicle as a representative of
a narrative of repossession,
just because he's
so vulnerable at
the end of the novel.
But I think that Hemingway
actually has stepped in and
provided one form of authority
or intervention that allows
us, possibly, to read the novel
as affirming something
about Robert, so that he's
not totally a loser at
the end of the novel.
And that has to do with a very
stylized, very deliberate
narrative structure of
For Whom the Tolls.
You notice that the first line
of the novel reads, "He lay
flat on the brown, pine-needled
floor of the
forest, his chin on his folded
arms, and high over head the
wind blew in the top of pine
trees." And the very last of
the novel, "He could feel his
heart beating against the pine
needle floor of the forest."
So Robert's totally alone, but
in the end is the beginning.
And so it is that impersonal
narrative structure
that he's not dead.
It's almost as if he were
beginning all over again, that
the story is going
to begin anew.
It is that formal structure, the
formal mirror effect, that
allows us to entertain the
illusion that not all is over,
even though we know that
physically it is over, that
there's no way it could have
a different ending or that
things could go on.
But nonetheless, the form of
the narrative is such, it
feels like the beginning
rather than the end.
And maybe this is really the
best that Hemingway can do for
Robert, is for the reader
to want this to be a new
beginning, and for the
reader to feel that
this isn't the end.
This is the best that we
can do for Robert.